the typical approach to designing
instruction of any kind at the textbook
a lecture and so forth involves a
professor who has expertise in a domain
reflecting on that expertise and using
that to design an instruction and that
approach is basically fundamentally
flawed a much better much more effective
way to design a instruction that
enhances student learning outcomes is to
have a deep understanding of the nature
of expertise that you want students to
develop as well as an understanding of
students typical errors that they may
make on their way to that expertise it
has been shown that a instructional
design based on one of these accurate
cognitive models of learners produces
much more effective instruction however
the approach is to develop these kinds
of models are quite expensive they
involve a lot of interviews of experts
and repeated analysis of such an
approach so what we have done is
developed a way to use data collected
from educational technologies to make
that a process of building a detailed
understanding of expertise and of
learners much more cost effective our
approach to using data involves a
statistical modeling and machine
learning and it's been applied in two
data sets from a variety of educational
technologies indicating that it is quite
scalable we've used it with data from
intelligent tutoring systems for
mathematics online courses for college
level statistics for example even
educational games like a game for
helping students learn fractions in all
of these cases the approach involves
using the data to understand places
where students have trouble breakdowns
in the learning process where the
learning curve doesn't go down smoothly
in those cases we can identify flaws and
existing models and improve them and
the key to this is that this is being
done by an algorithm thus it's quite
possible to apply it to multiple data
sets we have demonstrated this approach
this learning factors analysis algorithm
across 11 different data sets and in all
cases it was able to discover a better
cognitive model of learners than had
been created by experts before the
consequence of this approaches that we
can discover these improved models and
use them to redesign instruction and it
has been shown repeatedly and you can
see that in other videos here that that
such model-based design of instruction
leads to better student learning
outcomes the great thing about this
current work is that we've demonstrated
how we can scale this kind of
data-driven intensive approach by using
an automated learning algorithm to apply
it across multiple data sets through
data lab you can apply this approach to
your own data whether it's massive
online course data or educational game
data intelligent tutor data any kind of
educational technology data can be
uploaded to data lab and algorithms like
this one can be applied so that you can
use them to improve student learning
outcomes